the united states economy is officially
in a recession we just got the brand new
gdp data from q2 and it was negative
that is two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth which meets the
technical definition of a recession now
many of you have probably heard the
white house and other people in
positions of power and influence start
to gaslight the american people on what
actually defines a recession regardless
of what they say professional market
participants and sophisticated investors
all agree two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth means that we are in
a recession now this is absolutely
incredible because economists and market
forecasters they actually were
predicting positive gdp growth it's
understandable when they make a mistake
and they don't actually nail it and
they're off by a few percentage points
but to think that it's going to be
positive and it ends up being negative
that's outright asinine now of course we
also know that the federal reserve has
made two major mistakes over the last 12
months
first they were conducting quantitative
easing and holding interest rates
artificially low when inflation was
already over seven percent last year
now the federal reserve has been hiking
interest rates as we headed into a
recession in both scenarios the federal
reserve has been behind the curve
now i'm not one of the conspiracy
theorists i don't think that there's
some master plan for a controlled
demolition of the american economy i
actually think that the federal reserve
economists and market forecasters
they're trying to do the right thing
it's more of a hanlen's razor situation
don't assign malice to something that
can simply be explained by ignorance but
that doesn't change the fact that we
have high inflation in america it's at a
40-year high and now we're also in a
recession hello stagflation in these
scenarios it is a lose-lose if the fed
does not act we will continue to have
persistently high inflation if the fed
destroys demand as they've outlined as
their goal we will head deeper and
deeper into a recession
ultimately the federal reserve is going
to have to capitulate in one direction
or the other my guess is that the
federal reserve will capitulate they
will have to mitigate the recession and
just let people live with high inflation
that's not a great solution but it's the
best of the worst possible solutions
ultimately the u.s economy is in a very
perplexing and unique situation
we still have pretty strong employment
and consumer spending has not fallen but
we see gdp contracting we see high
inflation and we also see the federal
reserve is worried about where we could
go from here ultimately you have to
simply look at the data you have to be
willing to admit the problems and the
potential solutions we're in a recession
regardless of what anyone says and we
have high inflation and is likely higher
than the official numbers
lose lose situation what you at home
have to do is you have to make sure you
have a strong balance sheet you have to
optimize your cash flow and you simply
have to try to survive the next six to
12 months get to the other side and you
earn the right to thrive during the next
bull run
but until then
get ready for a bumpy ride